[Music]
so Call of Duty for whatever reason has
now implemented supply drops which are
like these loot crates that you get
randomly um for some reason it seems to
pop up more after you die like in the
beginning of the match I don't have a
Rhyme or Reason of how it works yet um
but you know once you get stuff you
start getting different tiers of of loot
you have enlisted which is the green
stuff uh you have professional which is
the blue gear and then you have the
elite which is the kind of orangey gold
color um those are random uh on top of
like right now all you're seeing is guns
but there's also uh like armor pieces
that you can get uh these are just for
Aesthetics uh whereas the weapons are
you know they have modifiers on them
that you don't normally have on your
regular versions of like the
rw1 so in this case you know you have
the holiday it comes with an Acog scope
so you don't have to invest a point into
a scope but you lose a point of accuracy
to gain two range so a lot of the
weapons that you're going to get from
the loot crates are ENT there's always a
trade-off in most cases I haven't seen
anything too crazy I think the only gun
that I've seen that's like oh my God
this is like really good is the hbr 3A
insanity um it seems to have more
positives than negatives and so I mean I
guess there are a few things like that
in the game but like I said for me right
now they kind of seem lacking and I'm
not even sure if they're like that much
better than the normal version um but
yeah um on top of that uh you can also
get double XP and you can also get
reinforcements but um yeah the
reinforcements are like Titanfall burn
cards in the sense that you get this
extra orbital care package that at the
beginning of the round you'll see a
timer that's on top of your uh score
streaks and when the timer is up you'll
get that orbital care package and then
depending on the the version of the
orbital care package that you got it'll
either be again unlisted professional or
I think Elite uh and those will yield uh
either a perk that you get for the rest
of the map or some type of you know mid
value or high value depending again on
what tier you get um
like a drop so you can get anywhere from
you know like a stage kind of score
streak or like UAV or an assault drone
that has like a bunch of stuff um so
that's kind of cool and then um the
other cool thing about the getting the
items and whatnot is if you don't need
them or you don't care about the
Aesthetics of the you know the look of
these armors and whatnot you can
actually go ahead and sell anything
that's professional um enlisted
or Elite so for example you can redeem
this for
XP uh the enlisted gives you 500 XP
whereas let's say these um professional
boots they'll give you
1,000 so Elite um gives you 2,000
XP so you know these are all things like
if you don't need it you can help you
know level up faster um and yeah we'll
see kind of how this turns out in terms
of like the supply drops uh I'm not
necessarily sold it took me forever to
actually get my first Elite weapon and
it was a shotgun so I wasn't really
super happy about that but I'm sure
other people have had better luck so
good luck to everyone that's playing and
um you know leave your comments below
and tell me your stories if you uh won
the lotto or not cuz I sure as hell not
won the
[Music]
lot
enemy UAV
[Music]
above